bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end vous le
savez votre émission hebdomadaire dédiée
à vos idées de sorties culture loisirs
et sports du week-end pendant 26 minutes
au cours de cette édition nous parlerons
de la fin de saison d'yves live avec
michael l'oukase ce dispositif vous
connaissez un ce dispositif
d'accompagnement artistique qui
participe au développement des musiques
du département sélectionnant les
artistes locaux et puis évidemment tous
les rendez-vous au cours de l'émission
de votre week-end mais tout d'abord
place à notre nouvelle chronique idées
de sorties avec yolande torres
je le disais petites nouveautés dont le
7-8 week-end cette saison yolaine torres
viendra désormais de temps en temps sur
l'émission pour vous donner un petit peu
son coup de coeur en quelque sorte pour
une idée de sortie bonjour et yolaine
merci je me devais être présentés alors
pour cette première ce premier passage
quel est votre coup de coeur alors mon
coup de coeur pour ce week end c'est une
exposition qui vaut le détour nous
partons loin jusqu'en nouvelle zélande
donc c'est sabine un berner qui nous
propose qu'ils nous proposent ces
photographies des spurs inédite alors
parmi elles des chauves-souris qui
galope ou encore des reptiles toujours
plus surprenants les uns que les autres
je ne vous en dis pas plus et je vous
laisse découvrir ce reportage
on n'a pas le fait d'une dernière fille
auteur photographe et depuis quelques
temps je travaille pour la
nouvelle-zélande pour présenter leur
travail
et puis pour préparer un livre et des
expositions j'ai une double vie ça fait
25 ans que fut avocat et je suis
toujours avocat d'ailleurs et avocats
plein temps
c'est pas très éloignée en fait mon
travail d'avocat de ce que je fais
aujourd'hui assez étonnamment même si je
suis auteur photographe donc là je
travaille pas et les codes avec des
appareils photo mais je raconte des
histoires et surtout je vais à la
découverte pour chercher pour comprendre
pour expliquer la nouvelle zélande 7
pays mon coeur c'est un cetain penikett
extraordinaire par sa faune par sa flore
et surtout par ses habitants par leur
implication c'est un univers qui c'est
qui s'est déplacé seul qui reste au
milieu de l'océan pendant 80 millions
année qui a été découvert il ya entre
700 à nous d'en de cela donc c'était
hier et qui pendant toute cette période
est resté sans mammifère terrestre ce
qui veut dire que la vie s'est
développée avec des chemins qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les nôtres avec les
oiseaux qu'ils étaient les rois de
l'archipel avec des insectes
extraordinaire des reptiles et comme
elle est restée protéger on y trouve
encore des espèces extrêmement ancien
hein on y trouve les cataractes 200
millions d'années des grenouilles 200
millions d'années des oiseaux terrestres
et puis surtout des animaux avec une
naïveté
écologiquement une naïveté qui est qui
et qui est très touchante ils sont beaux
ils sont très spéciaux ils sont
intelligents ils sont très attachés
je continue à travailler avec la
nouvelle zélande maman proches j'y
retourne parce que j'ai encore beaucoup
de choses à faire avec eux et puis après
ben jedo et d'autres pays en tête je
voudrais continuer à travailler avec le
scientifique à elle des rangers se
continue à chercher des histoires et les
ramener
alors ça vous tente anthony ah oui
surtout les chauves-souris qui galope
c'est plutôt assez curieux en tout cas
sachez que avant qu'elle ne reparte en
nouvelle zélande ans comme elle le dit
dans le reportage sachez qu'il vous est
possible de la rencontrer ce week end à
rambouillet c'est un binôme dernière
propose en effet deux visites guidées
pour découvrir son exposition au palais
d'auron donc la première c'est samedi 27
septembre de 17 heures à 18 heures et la
deuxième dimanche 28 de 14 heures à 18
heures une petite info pour terminer
cette exposition fait partie d'un
festival qui se déroule jusqu'à dimanche
c'est le festi photos d'autres clichés
d'autres animations sont donc à
découvrir ce week end dans toute la
ville rendez vous sur le site internet
de l'office de tourisme de rambouillet
pour tuer tout toutes les informations
merci yolaine et donc du coup samedi ou
dimanche on se retrouve un créneau pour
aller revoir cette exposition à très
bientôt et yolaine sur le 7-8 week-end
gérard mannoni on passe à la sculpture
expose ses oeuvres en ce moment au musée
de la ville à montigny le bretonneux ce
n'est pas un inconnu de l'agglomération
l'artiste a déjà participé à un projet
collectif autour de la place de la gare
dans les années 70 souvenez-vous il a
aussi réalisé une sculpture pour la
ville de guyancourt il revient là en
invité d'honneur en quelque sorte pour
expliquer son travail sérieux comme il
dit catherine vu la tôle a rencontré
gérard mannoni et sculpteur il se
présente comme un artiste non figuratif
qui aime prendre son temps je suis un
sculpteur qui travaillent très lentement
je remets beaucoup souvent mais nous
avons gelé reprend peu à peu
où trouver un équilibre
qui vous convient et tant que c'est
équilibré par n'est pas trouvée on
continue à travailler sur l'oeuvre
j'aime bien me souvent me rapprocher
d'eux des problèmes des musiciens comme
un musicien
trouve l'inspiration pour construire une
symphonie
girard mannoni n'aime donc pas les
fausses notes la musique son domaine de
prédilection la médecine aussi mon père
était médecin ne fera pas souvent ma la
profession
du travail des médecins je me le suis un
artiste et peintre un peu pareil qu'on
se trouve dans un
espace qu'on lui demande d'animer il
faut bien qu'ils trouvent quelque chose
qu'ils ne
soient pas malades qui tient debout
gérard man ni à travailler plusieurs
matières la pierre et le plâtre à ses
débuts puis le bois le métal l'acier
l'aluminium son attachement à saint
quentin en yvelines et particulier ses
vingt ans de ma vie de sculpteurs
explique-t-il en souriant dans les
années 70 travail en effet conjointement
avec l'architecte de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines pour produire un
escalier extérieur mais le projet
n'aboutit pas vingt ans plus tard gérard
manot n'y revient à guyancourt pour y
réaliser la place jacques brel ça fait
quand même le travail le plus le plus
complet que j'ai fait
les travaux d'enfants mais
moi j'appartiens peu à saint quentin en
yvelines
au musée de la ville une cinquantaine
d'oeuvres est exposé également les
croquis très détaillées de gérard
mannoni jusqu'au bout l'ont qu'il
dessine lui-même une précision que l'on
retrouve aussi dans ses travaux pour
pierre cardin parce que vous aimeriez
qu'on dise de vous
c'est du travail sérieux là actuelle
bande faire une sculpture c'est à la
portée de tout le monde enfin des
enfants les vieux toutes et tous
s'il n'y a pas vraiment une profondeur
de pensée sur panne un sérieux
allez une autre idée de sortie expo
jusqu'à ce samedi 27 septembre l'espace
bar gay à bois d'arcy mais talonneur le
street art une exposition qui présente
la vision sur toile de trois artistes
urbains rencontre avec l'un d'eux au
cours du montage des dernières toiles
aurélia de bissy et patrick jacques de
dixmude
le que quelques tableaux accrochés et
l'exposition sera fin prête fruit du
travail de trois passionnés de street
art ce mouvement artistique né dans les
rues début des années 80 exposition
collective et à retrouver à bois d'arcy
à l'heure où les tableaux de street art
sa rage dans les galeries et vente aux
enchères des grandes métropoles l'espace
barragué accueille les oeuvres de
l'association arcisienne grafite parts
jusqu'au 27 septembre on est tous issus
de la culture hip hop du street art on a
commencé par tout ce qui était graffiti
donc lettrage sur toile et on a ensuite
modifié notre style au fur et à mesure
des années donc ils font tout en gardant
ce côté hip hop on a un peu changé les
styles en se basant sur des portraits
donc ça peut être tout ans a peut être
des images que l'on voit sur internet
qui nous plaisent
des portraits engageant des portraits
engager des reproductions de photos
d'artistes ou de personnages de films
exposition présente ici une vision sur
toile de trois artistes urbains cette
toile donc c'est un enfant prises par un
photographe donc lors du conflit israélo
palestinien
je l'avais cris de gaza j'ai utilisé
uniquement
de l'acrylique j'étouffe repense aux
oeufs
chose que je n'avais jamais fait
auparavant j'ai toujours utilisé donc
des fai proposent cas où des pro
marqueur à noter enfin que l'association
propose également toute l'année des
cours de dessin
est alors deux autres idées de sorties
loisirs on va dire tout d'abord la 11e
édition de poésie bling que vous
connaissez bien ce festival dédié à la
poésie dans le département 15
manifestations vont se dérouler du 26
septembre au 5 octobre prochain
l'occasion de rencontrer des poètes dans
des endroits un petit peu différent
comme des églises des médiathèques ou
plus classiquement les traditionnels
librairie c'est l'événement culturel du
début de l'automne twenty fort 24 en
français pour 24 heures de spectacle de
danses et de concert ce samedi 27
septembre au vélodrome national de
montigny le bretonneux qui s'est associé
avec l'association juste debout déjà à
l'origine de l'un des plus grands
festivals de danse hip hop et qui
déplace pour son étape parisienne
notamment à bercy plus de 15000
personnes depuis dix ans allez on passe
à notre page musicale
et en début d'émission après une année
de formation pédagogique
d'accompagnement artistique et de
diffusion pour huit groupes yvelinois
sélectionner le réseau du cri clôture la
saison
2013-2014 d'yves live au café de la
plage à maurepas ce week-end et pour
dresser un petit peu le bilan de cette
saison et nous dévoiler un petit peu
aussi le programme de dimanche mickaël
lukasz le coordinateur divaguer présent
sur le plateau du ctu et week-end
bonjour à vous merci d'être là à
quelques heures d'un nouveau spectacle
alors déjà on va on va revenir sur
dimanche le programme comment ça va se
passer au café de la plage alors déjà
pour nous c'est une expérimentation un
dimanche on faisait toujours ça le
vendredi ou le samedi soir donc là on a
voulu changer faire ça en après midi
donc ça commence à 15h il y aura de la
musique de 15 heures jusqu'à 20 heures
et effectivement les huit groupes yves
live vont se succéder pour ceux qui
connaissent le café de la plage il ya
deux semaines donc du coup on pourra
alterner d'une scène à l'autre sens
voilà on laissera cinq minutes aux
fumeurs entre les entre chaque concert
voilà mais on leur demandera de revenir
quand même pour encourager les groupes
qui jouent le concert est gratuit parce
qu'on voit là on a envie de le proposer
un maximum de gens et alors sûr c'est
sur ces groupes donc là vous dit rien
c'est huit groupes on voit par exemple
bazar et bémol blue thunder tisot ya
c'est un petit peu tendance pop rock
cette année on peut dire ça comme ça
alors il ya une vieille petite tendance
pop rock qui se qui se détache mais
globalement c'est assez c'est assez
critique ainsi rapidement
effectivement on a on a des groupes pop
mais chacun différents dans leur style
qui sont blue box
and light qui est plus dans une pop
électronique un peu plus ambiante un peu
plus planantes
et lolito quai dans un espèce de power
rock assez à ses api voilà les jaloux
tous les sensibilités elle est
maintenant dire aussi du rap du métal de
la chanson effectivement un que les
groupes que vous avez cités est alors
pour voir un petit peu ce que cela donne
je vous propose de regarder l'extrait
d'un clip du groupe anéchoïque au rom on
regarde un petit peu ce que ça donne
comme vous disiez c'est assez éclectique
mais l'a par exemple avec anéchoïque
room c'est plus du dub rock métal
c'est vraiment le groupe on va dire
qu'ils jouent le voit quitter proche du
métal donc pour les amateurs de gros
rock de gros son ce sera ce groupe là
mais voilà il ya aussi encore une fois
pop rap rien à voir non pour tout le
monde on cherche pas forcément
l'éclectisme à tout prix mais il se
trouve qu'on l'a on en est ravi mais par
rapport à ce concert c'est mes grosses
banques font partie du dispositif yves
live appelée no un petit peu justement
la mission d'yves live bas donc c'est ça
alors on a et vous ne l'aviez fait le
plaisir d'être présent pour capter des
images l'hiver dernier fêter les 20 ans
de ce dispositif donc cessé un dispostif
anciens c'est le plus vieux même de tous
ces dispositifs qui existent en france
donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir travailler
pendant un an avec avec des groupes
qu'on dit en développement enfin des
groupes qui veulent devenir
professionnels et de leur proposer comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure un des
formations administratives et des
rencontres avec les coccinelles pour
qu'ils apprennent le secteur mais aussi
pouvoir travail artistique du travail en
résidence avec des intervenants et nous
on est un réseau de lieux de musiques
donc on a les scènes aussi pour pouvoir
les faire jouer pour cette année rien
justement c'est pas l'objectif n'est pas
de les faire progresser juste sur le
chant la musique les instruments c1
c'est un projet global voleurs ou leurs
données sur les sponsors de tremplin
pour une future carrière peut-être en
tout cas voilà ça s'adresse vraiment
j'en profite pour faire le lien parce
que je sais qu'il ya pas mal de groupes
qui commence à me solliciter donc le
prochain appel à candidatures à lyon
février prochain
je dis ça parce que ça s'adresse
vraiment à des groupes qui ont déjà
quand même un bac g un vécu et qui
vraiment encore une fois et essaye de se
donner les moyens à terme moyen terme de
pouvoir en vivre avec toutes les
difficultés que ça mais voilà un peu les
groupes auxquels s'adresse oui il ya le
site internet du cri un pur pour
s'inscrire évidemment à eau cession
d'yves live sur c'est sur ces groupes
depuis 20 ans a été créé en 92 6 jeux si
je ne me trompe il y en a quelques-uns
qui ont réussi à percer un petit peu sur
la scène nationale ça montre que peut
être ce qu'on apprend à yves la halle ça
sert et ça permet de grandir tout
doucement tout cas alors nous moi je
considère vraiment cons et des
accompagnateurs à un moment et qu'on
peut peut-être permettre d'accélérer les
choses parce qu'on a la possibilité
d'offrir certaines choses voilà il se
trouve qu'effectivement il ya des
groupes qui ont eu une belle carrière
est-ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
les groupes existent se séparent mais
qu'à l'inter de ces groupes et de
musiciens confié blake des carrières
professionnelles continues donc on a des
musiciens maintenant qu'ils wax tailor
par exemple avait fait yves like deux
fois avec des groupes différents les
musiciens de gauche trois démissions de
gauche avaient été dans des villages sur
le groupe il y en a certains maintenant
que je veux que johnny hallyday quand je
vais tenir mais voilà pour vous dire qui
on a aussi beaucoup d'acteurs possibles
absolument et à côté de ça sur les
groupes les plus connus bas
un des plus récents à l'heure actuelle
c'est danakil avec qui on a travaillé à
quelques années les blérots de ravel
évidemment à qui je m'inscris en plus
ils entament leur dernière tournée leur
tournée d'adieu donc oui il ya pas mal
de est ce qui est intéressant avec ce
dispositif ça montre quand même tout le
vivier qui a en termes musicale sur sur
le département absolument c'est nous on
essaye un peu d'avoir une vision du
nombre de groupes qui assurent
département c'est impossible d'être
exhaustif mais nous mêmes on en recense
entre 1000 et 1200 rien que sur le
territoire des yvelines donc c'est
énorme tout un vivier que vous pourrez
donc voir et écouter donc ce dimanche au
café de la plage à maurepas à partir de
15 heures jusqu'à 21 heures et à partir
de 20h on invite le public à rester avec
nous on a fait en sorte que l'été indien
se poursuivre il fait beau donc on fera
un petit barbecue à côté de la salle du
café de la plage avec les artistes avec
l'ensemble des gens du réseau qui
travaillent sur ce concert est donc on
invite le public à venir manger un bout
avec nous pour pouvoir échanger un petit
peu avec seulement les artistes et
surtout entrée gratuite entrée gratuite
parfait merci beaucoup si elle est
repassée puis on suivra évidemment ce
cette nouvelle édition du dernier
concert au café de la plage à très
bientôt
le onzième des festivals fait la
promotion entre personnes handicapées et
grand public ce festival musical a lieu
ce vendredi 26 et samedi 27 septembre au
champ de mars à paris et parmi les
artistes présents sur scène dès ce
vendredi soir des choristes dans dix
voix accompagnée du clae siens georges
smit nous les avons rencontrés lors
d'une répétition ce jeudi à l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
catherine mulato et patrick jacq de
victimes
laissez vous bercer vous aurez forcément
reconnu ses célèbres morceaux des
beatles à celle un désert qui sera
interprétée sur le champ de mars à paris
ce vendredi soir à l'occasion du
défistival par georges schmit et la
chorale andy voit tous réunis sur une
même scène pour un concert de la
tolérance il peaufinait les dernières
répétitions à l'espace philippe noiret
des clayes-sous-bois c'est vraiment
intéressant de pouvoir travailler des
personnes handicapées en vente en guinée
mais voilà je suis vraiment ravi de
pouvoir les faire participer même sommes
une fédération nationale de chorales
notre fédération regroupe depuis 15 ans
130 chorale de personnes en situation de
handicap tous handicaps confondus toutes
générations confondues et on se définit
comme un vrai mouvement populaire de
chant choral comme les autres participé
à donner une image du handicap qui soit
joyeuse créative dynamique au travers du
chant choral
georges schmit s est d'associer dans ce
travail avec un jeune violoncelliste
très motivés par cette aventure il
souhaite populariser son instrument qui
dit il se rapproche de la voix et
proposer un vrai moment de partage pour
moi ils sont pas handicapés pour moi ils
ont ils ont une sensibilité et ils ont
une émotion à véhiculer et cette émotion
on larron là ressemble pour on ne se
moque pas d'eux on est là justement avec
ce concert vendredi soir à paris est une
grande première environ 10000
spectateurs sont attendus
allez on passe à vos agendas sport du
week-end
deux rendez vous incontournable pour ce
week-end tout d'abord la célèbre paris
versailles vous ferez peut-être parmi
partie par nombre de ses vingt-cinq
mille coureurs qui vont s'élancer de la
tour eiffel ce dimanche matin à 10
heures en direction de versailles pour
la 37ème édition de la grande classique
premier départ donc à 10 heures il y
aura aussi du foot féminin ce week-end
le championnat de promotion d'honneur
reprend ses droits et pour cette
première journée vous pourrez assister à
un classique désormais de ph entre
elancourt et taverny coup d'envoi à 15
heures ce samedi au stade guy boniface
aller avant de nous quitter on passe à
notre virgule et surtout notre chapitre
cinéma
un petit coup d'oeil sur les salles
obscures et les films du moment cette
semaine c'est cyril à date de l'espace
philippe noiret qui nous dévoile son
coup de coeur
cette semaine le coup de coeur de
l'espace philippe noiret et le film nos
étoiles contraire film américain réalisé
par josh boone depuis son enfance ase
elle a des problèmes respiratoires
l'obligeant à porter un tube à oxygène
en permanence sur les conseils de sa
mère elle participe à un groupe de
soutien où elle va faire la connaissance
d'augustus qui a perdu une jambe à cause
d'un cancer le jeune homme devient
rapidement proches dazelle du montrant
le bon côté des choses leur amitié se
transforme peu à peu en amour jusqu'au
jour où la maladie il revient les hanter
entre rires et larmes ce film est une
véritable ode à la vie où l'humour des
deux jeunes personnages l'emportent
rapidement sur les bons sentiments ce
mélodrame bien ficelé touche en plein
coeur le spectateur l'interprétation des
acteurs principaux est vraiment
excellente et que nos étoiles contraire
est à découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
vip nos régions
à quel point je te suis reconnaissante
pour notre petite fille la vie est belle
à la grèce
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi je vous
souhaite un excellent week-end sur tv
fil à très bientôt